now to another story we've been closely
following here at CBS News Brittany
Greiner her lawyer in Russia says the
WNBA superstar has been moved to a penal
colony to begin her nine-year sentence
for drug possession Russia has hundreds
of these prison camps and life inside
them is described as horrifying Our
Charlie dagada has more
this is not a building with cells this
looks like a strange Village like a
gulag labor camp
[Music]
former [ __ ] Riot band member and
activist Maria alyakina was imprisoned
in a Russian labor camp for nearly two
years penal colonies are a cruel Vestige
of the Soviet era remote gulags where
prisoners are held in barracks and
forced to perform labor political
prisoner Alexi navalny likened his penal
colony to a concentration camp the worst
nightmare for griner's wife shirelle who
spoke with Gail King in October she
could be moved to a labor camp
and
I
my brain can't even fathom it Greiner
was arrested at a Moscow airport in
February accused of carrying Vape
cartridges containing less than a gram
of cannabis oil into Russia then
convicted and sentenced to nine years in
prison but a forced labor camp takes it
to the next level and alucino says
Griner may feel even more isolated than
other prisoners I never seen anyone who
doesn't speak Russian inside the system
I have no idea how she will be how she
will what what she will feel
but it's quite tough experience and she
shouldn't go through it alone
it's just so egregious and so
frightening when I met with shirelle
what Brittany Greiner has was residue
from the hashish oil that was less than
the size of a raisin now she was taking
it for medical purposes I believe she
probably forgot that she had it but to
go from that to where she's going now
makes no sense very frightening somebody
who's Russia and say look it was the
most difficult experience of my life I
and you see those images of her we know
that she's being used as a political
Pawn you know I hope again that the
White House is paying attention and I
know that they've said to uh her wife
the family are but well that's why we
have to keep talking about this story
such a sad situation I mean to go from
uh you know you're when you're an
athlete your body what you put in your
body what you do with your body uh is so
tightly controlled and now to be where
she is it's hard to watch it really is
really